un rapport explosif publié aujourd'hui
par nos confrères de l'événement du
jeudi
il met en cause le centre national de
transfusion sanguine à paris et le
ministère de la santé de l'époque il y a
6 ans ce centre aurait laissé sciemment
en circulation du sang infecté destinés
aux hémophiles l'enquète de bertrand
edel dans un document confidentiel daté
du 3 juin 85 des médecins dont le
directeur du centre national de
transfusion sanguine s'interrogent déjà
sur l'attitude à tenir vis-à-vis de ces
lots de plasma contaminé par le virus du
sida
le centre national de transfusion
sanguine en informe alors le laboratoire
national de la santé qui dépend
directement du ministère ce dernier ne
fait pas immédiatement retiré du marché
les produits à risque
aujourd'hui on sent hémophiles transfusé
entre 80 et 85 sont séropositifs 180
d'entre eux sont morts bruno d'hollande
leur président a lui aussi contracté la
maladie
il ya certainement des problèmes
d'instruction des problèmes
d'organisation une ombre ou de la
transfusion sanguine confiance le type
de produits mais pour nous le
responsable c'est bien une et sert de la
chanter
c'est un problème qui était fou une
échelle on dit que gouverner c'est
prévoir
c'est aussi avoir de moyens et ça je
crois que c'était typiquement le rôle du
ministère de la santé
deux mois après la publication du
rapport le ministre de la santé de
l'époque
edmond hervé l'actuel maire de rennes se
contente de ne plus rembourser les
produits entier mots philippe non
chauffés porteurs du virus
une attitude jugée scandaleuse par
certains hémophiles aujourd'hui atteints
du sida qui ont refusé toute indemnité
et qui ont porté plainte pour non
assistance à personne en danger